i'm not known for my athleticism on
stage right no no but you know
this oh that was nice this thing here
then first hey
hey it's evan carmichael and like
brendon burchard says no matter what you
are going to do
people are going to judge it and once
you anticipate that that is real
now you have power so let's help you
develop your power with brendan burchard
and my take on his top 10 rules of
success
need motivation watch the top 10 of
believe nation because i love it
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one beat procrastination i know that
every single one of us procrastinates me
too so it's okay
the issue is can you set yourself up so
you do less of it
i believe you can you're more likely to
do something
if you have already prepared
and stepped it through
you're already more likely to do
something if you already prepared and
stepped it through what does that mean
it means if you want to
not procrastinate on monday
sunday night i want you to sit down and
do this simple little thing
project plan
i know it's not sexy please don't make
fun of me right now it's not sexy i know
it's not sexy and it will change your
life forever
the day before
the days in which it's required that you
really get stuff done i want you to sit
down
and project plan i don't mean tomorrow
write down your to-do lists that is one
element
of project planning
but i want a bigger picture i want you
to be thinking about the big projects
that you have coming up and i want you
to have written out
these steps that it's going to take the
big steps that we'll take to accomplish
this project and this project and this
project with a timeline for each of them
and then work backwards from that to
create tomorrow's to-do lists
but here's what's funny
if listen list if your mind can't see
completion
if your mind
cannot see completion meaning you don't
know the path
you don't have clarity
on the path to fulfill or complete
something if your mind can't see the
steps
your heart will ask to pause knowing
your next three steps
is not enough
your mind needs to see
all the steps through to completion and
that's what we call project planning
it's not super fun but it's saying okay
this is the big project here are the big
key activities the big buckets of
activities that would have to happen to
get it done here's the timelines those
big buckets have to happen okay then
these big buckets of activities those
have been broken down into tasks
and then into ultimately daily to do's
and if we don't have that like it's just
hard to act when you don't have a
complete picture
right you're kind of like uh
procrastinating what i do to avoid
procrastination each week
is every single sunday for me that's my
sunday review days sunday work days i'll
sit down and i'll literally step through
the entire week of all the major things
on my email or on my to-do list
i'll think about the bigger projects
and i'll just kind of step it all the
way through
and guess what
i enter the week
more engaged
more joyous and confident because i know
what the heck is going on
so if you keep procrastinating i promise
if it's not
lots of worry or it's not you know lots
of randomness it's you haven't seen it
through yet rule number two shift your
perspective i wasn't always at a
beautiful beach house i mean
i was when i started my career as a
writer and a coach an online trainer i
was living this tiny apartment in san
francisco all the money was going to my
rent i was literally my bed was
literally in the closet and i was
sleeping under the clothes hanging above
me uh i was in going into bankruptcy my
girlfriend was having to buy me food it
was
not an ideal situation but even then
people like hey you seem to have a
positive attitude to how
and the thing that gives you positivity
and the ability to deal with
difficulties is perspective and i had it
in a couple different ways one i always
had mentors so i hope you get a mentor
and you just share your stresses with
them because they'll help you kind of
baseline the expectations and the
challenges the second thing though that
i always did has helped my life so much
is that i
read and devour biographies
if you read the biography of nelson
mandela or martin luther king or
churchill or the roosevelts
and
it's
they dealt with so many structures so
many major difficulties and challenges
it's hard to really get overwhelmed by
your day oh you missed your internet
deadline brendan oh
you know what i mean it's like when you
have perspective i have a lot of clients
i have clients who who have have
literally like lost limbs lost jobs or
coming back from cancer or like you know
just lost a family member and and they
still are able to carry on and they're
so inspiring to me that when you see
other people's inspiring story makes you
go wow
and you don't have to see them and go oh
what a bunch of lucky bastards what you
should say is wow
what is their mindset what's their day
like how are they handling it how do
they delegate how do they plan how do
they prioritize and that's what i was
always looking for i always tried to
find people who were more successful
than me and ask how they did those
things how do you keep such a you know
fresh and positive mind when
everything's so crazy how how do you
deal with confidence issues how do you
deal with insecurity how do you deal
with times you fail how do you deal with
times when it doesn't work out i'm just
always in that conversation with people
around me
to learn how they dealt with it and that
perspective strengthened my heart and my
spirit rule number three anticipate the
haters strategy number one for dealing
with haters
anticipate them and anticipate that they
will always be there no matter how good
you do how successful you become how
much you donate how well you lead how
good of a human you are anticipate right
that old saying anticipation is power is
totally true i know no matter what i put
up i'm gonna get judged and hated why
because listen when the dalai lama puts
up something
he gets hatred and vitriol right when
the nicest person you've ever met says
something incredibly nice online if like
someone will post a picture of their cat
and say i love my cat isn't the cat cute
and someone will say that's the ugliest
cat i've ever seen aren't you weird for
liking cats and aren't you stupid for
having nothing else to post but cats
it's like the most innocent
simple things you can post a picture of
your child and people judgment judge why
you posted a picture of your child like
there's there is no way out at this
point so you must anticipate no matter
what you are going to do
people are going to judge it and once
you anticipate that that is real
now you have power like it's like when
you expect it like have you ever gone to
a halloween like haunted house
and you went around the first time and
everything scared the crap out of you
the second time you took a friend
through nothing scared you because you
know where the boogeyman jumps out
guess what every single time you post
something somebody might judge it right
people thought van gogh was crazy and
his art sucked people thought monet was
messing up you know more classical
renaissance style like the all the
greats have people who call them crazy
and judge them and hate on them why
would you think you're going to be
different
you know i think that's the challenge is
that so many people never learn their
lessons from being younger that judgment
always happens
and they never learn to get over the
fears of rejection they never learned to
get over the hatred and so what they're
carrying in their adult bodies and minds
is this tremendous fear
because listen if you don't learn to
anticipate it
then you're just going to always fear it
you're always going to be like oh wait
might this happen and then when it does
it throws you off
you know i've written six best-selling
books now and every single one of them
you know on amazon these books become
massive books in the personal
development self-help and psychology
fields right massive bestsellers
and inevitably you go there there's
going to be hundreds or thousands of one
star comments next to the hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands of five
star comments right we'll get one email
that says oh my god brendan this book
changed my life and another email that
says your piece of crap
why would i let any of them
move my center
right i don't let the positive stuff in
the world move my center i don't want
the negative stuff move my center
because when you really anticipate that
you're going to get it you can also
learn to anticipate how should you deal
with it
like you need to make a decision today
how you're going to deal with that next
hater because they're coming for you and
the bigger you get the more they come
the bigger you get the more horrible
they get the bigger you get the more
they attack you privately consistently
over and over and i don't say that to
scare you i say that's totally gonna
happen it's just like when you start a
business guess what you're gonna have to
pay more taxes that doesn't mean you
don't start your business it doesn't
mean you don't share your art just
because there's gonna be some haters so
please anticipate it's gonna happen then
anticipate how you're going to deal with
it i just go i'm gonna deal with this
great i'm not to let this throw me off
i'm going to value my art and my work
over the judgments of people who don't
know me don't know my art don't know my
work don't know my students don't know
what i'm trying to do in the world why
would you let somebody who doesn't know
you
control your feelings
why would you do that
so you got to anticipate that you're
going to get some of this and you're
going to stay centered you're going to
stay positive about it and that's the
better way to deal with this rule number
four be interested in other people how
to win friends and influence people let
me summarize the whole book
be interested in other people
it's like a 300 page book
five words describe it be interested in
other people
that's how you win friends and influence
people stop listening through the lens
of only your interests and your passions
and open up to hearing and encouraging
and listening when if you talk to me if
you and i go out i'm like this i'm just
like i'm just taking it in like keep
bringing it keep bringing it just shovel
it all my way keep bringing it and
you're like yeah but brandon people
shovel their stuff on me i'm like nope
the bad stuff goes right over here the
good stuff goes right in here it's like
just keep bringing it like you if you
want to be a great friend you will
listen
you elicit their passions
and i don't think people talk about
their passions enough
and obviously i'm a personal development
guy so i have a high opinion about this
oh my goodness
i think it's so important to be
passionate
and to be passionate you have to
experience the world
to elicit other people's passion you
have to talk about
what they've experienced in the world
learn their stories
listen to what interests them
you have to pull in the conversation
their passion their interests their
ideas i know i'm being repetitive here a
little bit but i think we really need a
reset on this one a real reset because
if you think about your favorite friends
to be around at the parties they're
passionate it doesn't mean
they're extroverted it doesn't mean
they're extemporaneous speakers it just
means whatever is going on with them i
have a friend who just
i can't even believe this guy
he's like he's a friend and a mentor
he's like 58 years old
he
every time he talks he just looks at his
shoes
and he's not loud
he's not clownish like me
he's just super internal and thoughtful
but everything he's so passionate about
what he's saying he just likes that he
just passionately barely moves he's just
passionate you just hear it he's back
he's
his voice isn't bad he talks like this
well you know i just it's so so
important and just
like
i wanted to pep up a little bit but he
doesn't need to his passion is there and
i connect with him on that
you all follow
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five visualize
yourself in the future you gotta see
yourself
in scenes
in your life that don't currently exist
and what i mean by that is you've got to
visualize specific scenes that you would
love to manifest in your life in the
future um maybe you guys know i'm from
montana right i'm from this tiny irish
mining town uh that was economically
depressed for a century by the time i
got there and my parents you know
raising us four kids i literally don't
know how they
made it i don't know how they supported
us and we really really struggled
but
somehow i i always could
visualize things for myself and i i
remember thinking one time when i got to
college i was like you know i would love
one day to live on a beach and i would
love to like get up in the morning
go walk on the beach swim a little bit
in the ocean have a nice breakfast sit
down with my journal and then go about
the day i could see myself talking with
people and new cultures and traveling i
could see myself being somebody who was
a person of influence in some way or
another and i had no idea how all that
was going to manifest but i did not fear
to dream or when the visions came in i
didn't like stop them and say well
that's stupid because i'm just a kid
from a poor town
i did not know that one day i could live
on my dream beach
that was not the point it was that i saw
the scenes and i allowed to dream about
them
you have a lot of visions and you have a
lot of dreams that you have where you
just go well that's stupid or i don't
like that or what would they think or
who am i to do that and i'm here to tell
you explore those visions maybe you were
given those visions and those visions
were a gift to you that you're supposed
to manifest
and so what i'd love for you to do is
think out 10 years 20 years 30 years and
just try to imagine scenes in your life
because what most people do is they
don't see scenes in their life they just
write down to-do lists and goals
and so every day it's about a to-do list
and they're trying to just be more
effective and productive each week
but they're not seeing the bigger
picture so even though they're getting
their to-do lists done they got a lot of
goals they're not excited they're not
enthusiastic they they don't have that
vision pulling them forward
and so see the scenes that you might
have in the future with your family you
know see the scenes that you would have
in your personal lifestyle like how do
you live what do you do where do you go
see the scenes of yourself performing or
doing your work or your career see the
scenes of yourself happy and fit and
healthy
and explore those and i mean
every day
like visualization isn't something you
do once in a while on a birthday or when
it's new years it's like every day so
you guys know i wake up every morning
and i stretch for about 15 or 20 minutes
if i don't do my morning workout
then i read some motivation or
inspiration for 20 minutes then i sit
down with my high performance planner i
write down my day and then i push away
from having writ down that and now i
just start seeing the scenes of the day
how can i do them with joy and
excellence i start visualizing a bigger
picture and seeing just what comes in
about my future i'm consistently engaged
in
future thinking
future envisioning and it's not like
everything has come true
but i'll show you know
the the scene that we're in right here
from montana
to this scene i envisioned 20
years ago
think about that 20 years ago i was like
i'm gonna live on a beach one day
when i lived in montana in the mountains
as far away as possible i am telling you
more is possible than you actually know
right now rule number six delegate more
you want to be more disciplined
you're going to have to delegate more
you want to be more disciplined to what
really matters for you you're gonna ask
for assistance for help you're gonna
have to build the team you have to
socially engage people to support
your focus
it's just real like every writer i know
who's become a major writer
has assistance
meaning they get some of their their
spouse their partner
their agent a personal assistant
somebody is helping with a part of their
life so they can focus on that thing
right it's hard to be a disciplined
writer if you're doing everything under
the sun you need time to be able to
write which means there's some things
you can't handle under by yourself
and you're going to delegate that and if
you're like well brendan i don't have
anyone to delegate to then i'm like then
stop saying yes to everything under the
sun
stop putting more and more on your plate
when you can't handle what you already
got babe we got to go no no no
if i want to be disciplined
i got to choose a few things
say no to the rest
delegate the rest
and do what is here
you don't lack discipline you're taking
on too much
you don't lack discipline you're taking
on too much
or you don't have a schedule or you
don't know your outcome rule number
seven control your self-talk one unique
thing that i do is i find passages from
books that i really like sometimes it's
spiritual text sometimes it's just
something that really inspires me and i
read it out loud
and then after i read it out loud i give
kind of declarations like self-talk to
myself almost like spiritual self-talk
like i am grateful today for the
positive attitude that i have that's
going to allow me to approach my work
with enthusiasm thank you god for an
open enthusiastic mind willing to serve
today
i am excited about the things i get to
do today because other people would
dream of having my career and i get to
do it thank you god for this opportunity
to serve today and i'll say these things
over over and over myself it sounds
silly and maybe like affirmational but
the reality is it gets my mind
programmed to be thankful and to be in
charge
like i immediately by the morning guy
speaking it out i have taken control of
my self-talk for the day
so later on when overwhelmed sometimes
oh my god oh my god oh my god comes in
i'll be able to command and go hey
brendan
take a breath buddy it's not that big of
a deal just figure out what's the next
right action of integrity and take that
step right now you got this
by speaking to myself every morning in
positive ways i'm more able or more
skilled to speak to myself when it
really matters
that's your daily decorative declaration
some people pray to get command of
themselves or meditate and say things to
themselves as a mantra it's just
learning to control your self-talk in
your mind so that time is important you
can really do it rule number eight
master motivation we're gonna dive deep
into how do you gain some more emotional
mastery in your life so you can handle
those difficult times when you get
frustrated when you get down we get like
beat up and like chewed out and spit out
by the world
what are you gonna do to be your best
self that is the topic of today's
conversation that emotional masteries
part that emotional intelligence we hear
so much about that ability to handle the
difficulties and challenge of life with
grace or plume or being centered in the
middle of all this chaos and turmoil how
do you be your best that's the topic of
today we're talking about motivation at
a deeper level maybe you haven't had
with me before the utmost most important
area of emotional mastery is mastering
motivation now when i say emotional
mastery you're like wait isn't
motivation is a topic an area i'm like
no motivation
motivation is
an emotion
right a motivation is a motion emotion
that you feel
that you feel a drive a sense of hunger
a sense of want and sense of desire to
make something happen
i believe motivation is
one of the most important things we have
to master in our total emotional sort of
tool kit
right because if you can emotionally
feel motivated every day
almost everything else can fall in line
right if you're emotionally motivated to
be a better mom
be a better caregiver be a better parent
be a better lover be a better
entrepreneur be a better business person
be a better contributor to the greater
world when there's a motivation pulling
you forward
out of bed each day
into the office into real life
to be your best then everything changes
when you lose motivation you and i both
know the loss of motivation is the first
gate
to suffering
you lose motivation now you don't feel
like doing anything you don't feel like
doing anything you don't work out you
don't feel like working out you don't
feel like doing anything you don't feel
like doing anything you don't want to do
your goals don't feel like doing your
goals feel unfulfilled feel unfulfilled
feel unsatisfied feel unsatisfied feel
like life is meaningless it is a
slippery slope when you lose motivation
but the issue is no one has
motivation 24 7 all the time
motivation is an emotion you learn to
cultivate by using your mind your body
your greater consciousness
to ensure
that you feel that pull of purpose
that you feel that energy inside that
says i want to create i want to
contribute i want to be my best self i
want to connect with people
and so motivation is something we're
going to have to generate on a
consistent basis i know many of you are
at hpa and you hear me say you know all
the time you have to learn to bring the
joy because the power plant doesn't have
energy it generates energy motivation is
something me the motivation guy i have
the best selling book
of the entire century with motivation
the title it's called the motivation
manifesto if you haven't read it and the
motivation manifesto is like
if anything is is imbued in that book it
is like this ferocity and this
fierceness and this attention
to living our best lives but it has to
be like generated because even though
i'm the motivation guy there's plenty of
days i wake up and i'm like
i don't feel like it
there's plenty of days there's plenty of
moments where just like you i'm just
like i'd rather be lazy and do nothing
right now and that's okay that's that's
part of homeostasis that's part of our
our human body to want to power down to
relax to chill out
but too much of that
can lead to an unfulfilling life
so we must learn
to generate
the emotions
of drive desire go get in this whatever
you want to call
motivation
and so it's something that we have to
learn to stoke
motivation is an emotion we feel
by either luck
or by purposeful conscious design i just
choose to design it into my day every
single day motivation is driven by
certain things you have a spark you have
something that sustains it and something
grows it okay the spark of motivation
which is how i anchor into being
motivated each day
is ambition
all motivation begins with the desire or
hunger and ambition for more
whether that's more depth or more
connection or more contribution or more
abundance or more wealth or more love
like we just want more of something and
that says i want to go get that like we
see a fancier car it's better than our
car i want to go get that we see like a
deeper love of relationship between two
people i said i want that in my own life
sometimes it's a visual cue something we
see makes us want something right
they're not too far from here there's a
beach that i strolled on vacation
i don't know a couple years ago and i
said i want to live here
and it was a motivation it was a cue i
saw something desired it wanted it went
after it like so sometimes it's a visual
it's a cue out in the world that says i
want more of that thing
and ambition can be visually cued
for some people if you just wake up i
mean think about it you wake up you grab
your phone you're like
you know
and all of a sudden you don't have any
motivation instead you look through all
this stuff and all it did
is make you feel like you're not enough
or it distracted you or it upsets you or
created you know anger anxiousness
you got to be careful how you're using
cues to start your day
i use cues to start my day motivated
and those cues to start my day motivated
are things like i literally wake up and
uh i'll wake up and i'll think of things
that i'm i'm grateful for and that i
want to give in life
i'll wake up and i'll think about
someone i want to do something nice for
or surprised today i'll think of
something i can be excited about today
all as soon as possible in the morning
fit revisit my ambitions list my goals
list i'll look at them i'll not wander
through the day looking at social media
and then oh i guess it's time to work
and look at my goals it's like my goals
i mean in the first few minutes of the
day i'm revisiting them and what i'm
doing is when i'm looking at my goals or
my gender or my schedule i'm looking at
i'm thinking okay
why do i want this what would life be
like like this how could i go get it
what should i do today to make that
happen and that motivates me that's my
list of goals my list of ambitions the
things that can excite me in other words
it's very intrinsic
goals it's intrinsic rewards that i'm
after i'm like if i go do that i will
feel better
if i could have this i'd be happier
right it's not that i can't be happy
with now but i want to pull
like if i can have that future pull
that's going to motivate me to go do
stuff right i have to literally generate
that in my mind
and so when i have that connection in
the morning
that my takeaway for you is connect with
your ambitions every morning
very first thing in the morning
somehow part of your modern routine
connect with your ambitions look at them
why do you want them what would you get
from that how would you feel from that
what would that generate why would that
be more meaningful really connect with
that ambition every single morning and
you'll start to notice
you feel better
because remember if you're at hpa you've
ever attended our event or a seminar you
also know this reality
that motivation wanes
with attention
meaning if we don't give our ambitions
our goals a lot of attention the
motivation just goes away because
motivation is either fueled by our
attention
or by momentum
right it either takes reflection or
action
to generate serious sustained motivation
either reflection or action because
ultimately from the reflection that
gives us clarity
and clarity can give us confidence
or action can give us momentum and when
we have momentum
motivation is way easier to cultivate
generate and sustain obviously
so these are really important concepts
every morning get very close to your
goals ambitiously what are those things
that you want desire need and would
enjoy and what do you need to go to get
that's the intrinsic type of things that
things will feel good about the drive
satisfaction fulfillment meaning
excitement in us
but i also have my extrinsic
meaning my external cues or goals or
rewards that also i revisit so for me
example when i always tell you wake up
each day and at some point say who needs
me on my a-game
for me every morning i re-anchor down
into my relationships
i think about okay
if i don't show up today
and do a good job
then
my wife and i have a lower quality of
life
then i can't support my mom
then i can't support my team
then all these people who count on me
every day for motivation or count on me
for leadership or count on me for
support
they don't get that from me and i you
know i tap into that reality that if i
don't show up for somebody today
then you know what by the end of the
night i'll feel worse about myself but
also it will impact other people
because you cannot have real high
powered mental motivation
without a connection to other people we
are social animals so we have to think
about okay what should i do
how can i contribute in a way that
serves other people
so where the internal one is about self
and satisfaction and fulfillment and
meaning personally
that's happening into our own passions
desires wants and hungers that external
one is ultimately about service
about giving or taking care of or being
the caretaker of other people
and you cannot just keep starting your
day i guess i'll get some coffee and
read the news and see what's on social
media or hop into the car and listen to
trash talk radio or turn on the tv
and hope to find motivation later in the
day
like you want to kick off the day kick
off the day with motivation like get all
ready in the morning
immediately in a good state of mind when
i'm in a great state of mind it's like
bam the day goes and you know what if
you start the morning in the right frame
of mind motivated driven because you're
connected to what drives you and what
will serve other people then when you
start like running out of gas at noon
one two or three it's easier
to to like re-spark that flame then th
or their to fuel that flame than to
start a new fire
right because some people just keep
waiting they're they're they don't they
don't even think about i guess i should
be motivated until they've lost it
i want you to start the morning with it
and sustain it throughout the day by
revisiting remember
the secret to all of motivation is
revisiting those why's it's revisiting
that ambition that you have for your
life for more for others for
contribution that's everything
right that's everything
and if you get away from that too many
days too many weeks too many months i'm
just here to tell you you're really
going
to struggle so i hope that helps every
morning everybody every single morning i
really want you to connect with that
okay what am i motivated what am i
driven by and that's going to really
that's i can't explain how much that's
going to help you
you will feel it and you will know it if
you will do it every morning okay
motivation starts in the morning but
it's also sustained by that morning
frame of mind so that's really key
that's the first idea behind
motivation connect with your ambitions
first thing every single day give
attention to that every single day
here's something i don't often talk
about but it's important for me
because it's it's very easy for me to be
really effective in the mornings and
then that afternoon two three o'clock
and i could just be like
man
i want to go outside take a walk
come back turn on some netflix eat some
carbs
you know that can be my afternoon if i'm
not careful so here's what i do i have a
checkpoint in the mid-afternoon
to recognize reward appreciate
anything that i have done today
anything that i've done today and that
midpoint checkpoint for me on my phone i
just have an alarm mine tends to go off
around 2 30 or 3 o'clock in the
afternoon it just flashes to me and it
says
what's been great today
what's been great today
and so that will cue me all right it's
time to visit what's been great today so
i'll just think about something i've
done it could be like i answered 10
emails today that i have been avoiding
good job
it could be as simple as i made that one
call i said i was going to call did it i
shot that content created that thing
whatever
some kind like listen motivation is
often driven by recognition
so recognize what you have done so far
in the day
early afternoon
then what i do in order to keep myself
motivated even more because i've set my
mind i want to be a person who's
excellence driven
what i will do is i say okay
here's what's great so far and then i
asked you some question
how do i complete this day with
excellence just a simple touch point in
the afternoon how do i complete this day
with excellence
so i will look at the rest of the day
whether that's two hours more four hours
more five hours more six hours more
whatever it's going to be for me and i
go okay
how do i think through the rest of this
day with real excellence and when i can
connect with that i'm telling you
it's just it's just so part of me and it
really makes me want to serve so please
think about having a mid-afternoon
connection point to keep yourself
motivated you'll feel a whole different
quality of life come in i promise it's
it's a different experience for people
because most people they're just running
and gunning through the day they don't
realize uh or understand or accept how
challenging it is to lose motivation and
so they've gone many people they've gone
weeks without being motivated they're
going through the motions
but there's no energy
there's no emotional pull
towards something better and because
they're lacking that emotional pull what
ends up happening
they dog it they don't contribute as
much
they react and sort of create and now
all of a sudden a couple weeks later
they're like i don't know why i'm so
unfulfilled well no doubt you're so
unfulfilled because you haven't been
tapping into that emotion of motivation
when we lack motivation it is a slippery
slope to suffering
so please recognize that you must
cultivate more motivation
what else can you do well i'll tell you
it's like ambition
attention to those ambitions
effort towards those things i think all
of that is is really really really clear
but i also really believe that a lot of
motivation
is simply lost
because of fatigue
so let's say you're doing all those
things but you're wiped out you're tired
like a lot of motivation really rests on
how you feel physically if you feel
lethargic you feel tired you have the
flu
it's like it's harder to be more
motivated you can still do it by doing
what i've talked about re-cue yourself
reconnect with those things but
health-wise
it's really critical for you to say okay
if i want to be motivated long-term i
need to feel greater levels of mobility
and energy in my body so if you ever
hung out on me i'm constantly bouncing
and moving and breathing if you've been
with me at hpa you see some of these
practices this breath work that i do
that i'm activating and opening up my
body so that my body says let's go
versus
right so my body's not like oh i ate
this terrible thing instead my body says
i feel refueled i feel ready to go let's
go so i manage my
sleep my diet my health
in ways that support my mental clarity
and energy
and i know that
like sounds sometimes people think
motivation is just a mental game i'm
like yes but your mind and your body are
connected if your body is lethargic so
is your mind right that brain body
connection is real y'all and i know you
know that you've been sick you've been
tired there's times when you've been out
of shape you feel terrible so i'm here
to encourage you as i always do if every
single month in high performance i have
to cheer you on to get in better health
to prioritize your health to sleep good
to eat well to move
if i have to do that every single month
i will do that i will be a champion i
will cheer you on i want you in
excellent health this year so please
hear me cheer that on every single month
because i just know i get you in better
health
i get you in better mental health
we get you in better mental health it's
easier to sustain that fire and that
drive
that purpose that motivation that thing
will bring you satisfaction joy and
meaning i know you guys get this but i
want to fire you up today like this is
something you must fire up on your own
this
will be fleeting
of course it's fleeting if you never
look at it i tell you all the time no
wonder you're not motivated you haven't
thought about what motivates you in
three days
just think about that no wonder you're
not motivated you haven't thought about
what motivates you in three days every
morning i'm a deep dive in what's gonna
motivate me i get excited about i look
at like okay let's go
if i didn't do that
i need coffee
rule number nine reflect and reward
yourself i'm disciplined because to me
discipline being disciplined doesn't
sound like
i'm disciplining myself
what it means is i am
reflecting and rewarding myself for my
progress it's so important for you to
hear me say this
if you're lacking discipline
probably is because you've never
rewarded yourself
you've never reflected on how far you've
come you still think you're the same as
you were in your 20s and your 30s it's
like you've come so far and you're still
thinking like that kid because you let
your protecting mind your processing
mind your progress and mind run rampant
without the peace practices without that
moment those moments of purpose and rule
number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus clips is share your
troubles tell everybody
everybody who's important to you in your
life who you deal with on a consistent
basis what your dreams are and what you
want of this life and what are the major
activities you are working on this week
that might stress you out and when they
happen
that's a lot
but listen
one of the reasons people get
overwhelmed all the time is because the
people around them keep stacking more
onto their plate
but the reason they keep stacking more
on your plates because you've never told
them hey this is what i'm working on
these are the times it's crazy for me
please don't add anything during this
hour this day this week because i'm
already at max capacity i'm about to
freak out and lose my mind
by sharing that in advance
people can know when they got to walk on
eggshells around you a little bit when
they can be attentive to the needs and
the the stresses that you're dealing
with i think that's really important to
realize
what is it you're really after and is it
after what are you after
enough for yourself are you are you
limiting yourself based on your current
competencies a lot of people do that
they narrow their vision or their
ambition for tomorrow based on what they
can do today or who they are today
without realizing they can develop their
mastery their skills their competency
their knowledge their experience without
realizing they can become a better
person they can live into their highest
self they can live into the type of
person who could accomplish those goals
who could have those things so never
limit your ambitions based on your
current competencies never limit
yourself today based on your current
inadequacies because those can be
irrelevant tomorrow the main thing is to
have aim in life to have your own aim to
have your own ambitions not the
ambitions somebody told you you should
have or someone told you you're supposed
to be after because that's how we all
get on sort of you know sometimes a
corporate treadmill or we get on those
things where we just start trying to
live a life that's not even our own
because we're just going with everybody
but ambition liberates that your
individual ambition who you want to
become
what you want to do what you want to
contribute and the highest forms of all
ambition usually come down to your
creative expression your contribution
and your connection with others that
creative expression what is it you want
to create in this world and i mean get
your hands dirty doing you know not just
create some powerpoint once in a while
for some corporate thing but something
real and meaningful that you consider
art for yourself whatever that is even
if it is a powerpoint presentation right
but to do something that you find
artistic and meaningful that's our human
drive for creative expression
then what about contribution what's your
ambition to to give and to serve greatly
for others what do you really want to
give back or give to others what is it
and what about connection you know the
ultimate ambition and aim to have i
think for a lot of people is their
relationships to operate and have a love
that knows no bounds i mean a love that
is extraordinary it is amazing you can't
improve your relationship with your
family or your spouse or those that you
serve unless you have in some sense
about you that desire to love or give or
connect
more so today get clear what is it you
want and is it big enough for yourself
not limiting yourself based off your
inadequacies your competencies but based
on what you truly desire
last challenge take whatever that is
that you come up with and 10x it take it
by 10 times what would be 10 times that
ambition not just
because it's silly i know i know it's
kind of silly but to take that ambition
that you initially have which is usually
what we usually want is an impulse based
on who we are today and i just challenge
people no think bigger for yourself
because you are immense you are
magnificent you are powerful beyond your
current understandings so break through
that another level challenge your brain
to think even bigger for yourself even
it's just as an activity to break the
bounds of your current beliefs and
behaviors you deserve something
extraordinary in your life but at first
you have to want it what would i have to
do in social situations to be able to
you know develop some confidence what
would i need to do to develop a deeper
competency skill set talent ability in
this new area that will make me an
all-around stronger more competent and
capable person i think we should focus
on the plan to develop your strengths
much more than just stopping some of the
inadequacies or the worries those will
always
be there if you don't have them the game
is over
if i ever get to the point where i'm
backstage and i'm about to go out on
stage and perform for thousands of
people who've paid thousands of dollars
to see me who came from you know 40 plus
countries to be in the room if i don't
have any anxiety to that some
performance anxiety that's going to tell
me that's probably the day i should you
know turn it in
quit retire because it means i don't
care enough about it i want to
experience some anxiety i want to have a
little stress we know from high
performance studies that a little bit of
stress can give that edge in performance
as long as it's managed as long as it's
utilized as a tool to pay attention to
focus to execute versus as an excuse
to stop
so how have you been using anxiety as a
performance enhancement tool or an
excuse to stop
the world's highest performers use it as
a tool they get an edge from it they say
okay i'm nervous but that tells me i'm
in the game i better pay attention
and they also develop plans to develop
themselves to strengthen themselves in
all their areas emotionally socially
financially physically spiritually so
that those anxieties start to diminish
as they become more is stop
prioritizing
easy
stop prioritizing easy a lot of people
when they look at their to-do list of
the day they just start working towards
the easy things knocking off the easy
things get they think that's going to
get me some momentum it'll get me into
the day i'll feel like i'm succeeding
and the reality is it's making them less
likely to actually do the things that
count and how do you know this how do
you know if you're guilty of that you
know it if your day feels like there's a
lot of busy work
but there's an absence of your life's
work
you know what i mean if you don't feel
like your activities during the day are
really creating to your vitality to the
contributions you want to make with the
world to doing activities and tasks that
you really enjoy whose fault is that is
it the man's is it the governments no
it's like you're setting up your day you
can choose what to do with it maybe you
need to look at doing things that would
support you your health your vibrancy
your joy your real growth and
contribution in a more significant way
if you feel like there's always busy
work but it's not your life's work you
probably prioritize things at a larger
level
maybe incorrectly for you now i don't
know this i can't gauge it i mean i'm
just talking through here now as i look
and as you listen to me
all i can do is encourage you to just
look and say how have i been
prioritizing
have i had a structure have i had a
framework have i had ideas about what's
important to me in the world and i
always run my decision making through
those because if you haven't set that up
this is the time to do that for yourself
just because there's something that's
easy to do does not mean it must be done
today what i would rather you to do is
say i am going to prioritize things
today that will make significant steps
forward in my life these are i just say
if the opposite of stop
or sort of prioritizing easy is to
prioritize
progress
things that actually move the needle of
your life forward things that actually
contribute in ways that you find
meaningful and significant and
fulfilling and you know you deserve that
but sometimes you get caught up right
maybe you've just been caught up in
everybody else's you know hot mess
and your life thus became a hot mess
it's not because you are is that you
were just doing the easy things to
please people because you know that's
easy oh i'm gonna please some people
today
but what we need you to do is say what
would significantly move me toward my
dreams today what three things must
happen today that would be real movement
forward not like little checklists our
whole world has gotten so addicted to
little tiny checklists but they're not
doing anything meaningful they're not
checking off i'm living my life you know
so i want you to get back into what
would really progress me today stop
prioritizing easy start prioritizing
progress things that matter i want you
to take on something hard
every
day you do that you'll start to find
yourself
getting a little more confident a little
bit more momentum a little bit more into
that space where you feel like you're
doing things you were meant to do you
already know the thing about love
yourself and maybe in some ways you've
never allowed that
you've never noticed the beautiful
things you've done in your life
so you've never allowed yourself to love
yourself
but at some point
you've got to recognize that there's a
love that's beyond you
and beyond me and beyond your actions
and that love is whatever brought us
here alive today some would say it's
god's will and god's love some people
it's the randomness of the universe some
people it's nature some people it's
whatever
but there is something way beyond us
and there's a way to access that and a
way to honor that and the way to honor
that is to recognize that you are unique
about of seven billion people no one is
like you specifically
and
at least take that as a moment saying
okay
i'm meant to live my uniqueness
i'm out i'm supposed to love the things
that make me odd and weird i'm supposed
to love the things that make me strong
i'm supposed to i was made this way so
let me honor what's good about that and
what's not good about that let me work
on that let me set a schedule to get
better at that so that i can not only
honor what i've been given but i can
give something back to by getting better
and that aspect of doing that that
brings in so much joy and so much
strength in our life is love loving
ourselves loving the process and of
course the greatest way to believe in
ourselves is to love other people that
they become so grateful for us
that they give us some of that feedback
that they that there's so much
appreciation and love and joy in the
moment with others that you can't help
but just feel that vibe that there's
emotional contagion when other people
around you are feeling loved and cared
for and excited about life it's hard not
to rub off on you a little bit and you
start to say you know what life isn't so
bad and you know what i deserve to feel
good here right now too and you know
what you start getting some momentums
some wins you integrate those wins you
get some feedback to get better and all
of a sudden you start to believe in
yourself again all of a sudden you start
to live
the charge what makes a great person
these days
what really makes someone extraordinary
what makes somebody stand out what's
going to make you feel like you're
contributing your best like you're
making your difference and that you're
always aspiring to be a better human but
you're also achieving along the way i
would argue that that thing that makes
us great
is generosity
you know the ability to be generous to
others with your time your attention
your mentorship your care your love your
patience your forgiveness your
understanding your spirit your energy
when you are generous with who you are
people vibrate with that they feel it
they sense it and they're surprised by
it you know in a world today where no
one will even take time to say hello or
to call somebody or to show a measure of
appreciation when you do that you stand
out but you also light up in your soul
you know it it changes everything when
you're willing to be different when
you're willing to be generous with
people because really you know it's a
very biblical thing ask and you shall
receive
i also think that in terms of career and
in terms of chasing your dreams
give
and you shall receive you know give as
much of your heart and your spirit and
your life and your voice to this world
this time this day this person in front
of you because we only get one shot at
this life and today it never happens you
don't see it you know i'm blessed to be
here and shooting this video at my
writer's villa where i come to write and
now shoot these episodes and and i can
share with you uh you know all this when
i got here and what i think about this
space
it it came from a place position of
generosity and it came from a position
of generosity in my life so long ago
when i had a high school mentor mrs
baloo who believed in me she saw me take
some pictures and she said you know
those pictures are pretty good even
though honestly looking back they were
kind of crap but she cheered me on
anyway because i was putting effort and
she could see i was kind of passionate
about it and she said you know you could
probably write and and you could
probably shoot these uh shoot these uh
photographs and i had nobody ever really
told me i had any potential before and
here's this person for no reason saying
you could probably do this
and i started doing it and she'd cheer
me on and cheer me on and her generosity
of her time her effort her mentorship
she wasn't there was no reason she did
it she just believed in me but you know
what she believed in everybody around
her
she was always cheering people on always
rewarding effort always telling people
to pursue their passions and believe in
themselves and i'm here today i get to
do this work with you and millions of
people see these videos and hear me
online or watch my posts online or read
my emails every single week because this
woman
who was a teacher at a simple high
school in a simple town with a simple
beautiful generous spirit said i believe
in your kid well imagine like last night
i'm going on the stage right if i if my
identity says i am a public speaker and
it is important for me to be excellent
at this
and then i go on stage and i bomb
what does that say about me as a person
so we've got about 50 years of work in
psychology
the field of psychology saying do not
tie your efforts to your identity
because
that risk of disappointment or rejection
you know if the task fails
you shouldn't take that is as a defining
moment in which you'd say i am a failure
right so that's the risk and that's what
you know psychologists tell us to be
wary of except it turns out that high
performers flipped out on its face and
go well actually
um
no i do get bothered
if it fails i really get upset about it
i am attached to
the process here i i do care if it turns
out well i mean that's why they obsess
about the details that's why they care
about excellence is like no one obsessed
about the details who cares about
excellence unless it means something to
them
and there is a risk the risk is
you over attach
to
the process or the outcome
with your identity so that if the
process or outcome goes bad now you feel
bad about yourself as a human
and now you stop your progress
but i also tell people
there's a balance there
i actually wish more people would attach
some identity
to what they're doing they wouldn't go
through the motions as much i mean
i think what the world needs
less of is half interested parents
who don't have an identity that says you
know what
i'm going to be an excellent parent
i think we have a lot of ceos or
business people or entrepreneurs who
they've never stepped in and said you
know what
i'm a ceo
i own this business i am responsible for
paying the bills i am responsible for
making the money i'm responsible for all
these people's mortgages who work for me
like they i want them to own the
identity of a ceo because most of them
if you ask them about their identity and
their business they're kind of like you
come to find
they're kind of approaching it like
not even hobbyists
it's like if you want to win
your identity has to be tied into that
thing in which you are trying to succeed
at and give to and that takes a lot of
guts to put yourself all in for
something but who's ever contributed
something with tremendous impact without
being all into it i've never seen it so
i think the message of the book you're
right i'll get some flack i'm super a
lot of psychologists say don't don't
tell people to tie more of their
identity or my friends who are buddhists
will say but attachment is the form of
all suffering brendon have you not read
your spiritual attacks i'm like look out
calm down i've hung out with the dalai
lama i'm totally cool
but what i'm trying to tell you
is even the dalai lama
has a connection with himself as a
spiritual leader his identity is still
there that people
you know assume that you know we have to
release ourselves from having any
attachment to something but i'm like i
think
we all want to be present
and engaged fully
in the things that we are doing in our
lives
and that's going to require us to say
psychologically you know what i
i
am all in this the habit is generate
energy
okay not necessarily have energy create
energy create energy and what they do
the way we measure that was kind of
academic
mental energy which is tied to your
focus and your stamina and your ability
to manage complex tasks without too much
mental stress
number two is emotional energy
which is just the quality of your
positive emotions
and number three is physical energy
high performers are 40 percent more
likely to work out five times per week
than
the rest of their peers so that means
the top 15
most high performing people in the world
tend to work out five days per week
and that workout could be defined as you
know 45 minute brisk walk or you know
hit intensity or whatever it is but
40
more likely that's a huge finding and
what we found is high performers just
have
better well-being
and happiness and physical conditioning
than everybody else
one stunning finding was
uh
ceos senior executives and business
owners
they
report expending as much energy
as athletes who are competitive now i
can imagine yeah yeah i kind of i was
surprised by that i would thought you
know athletes would be ten percent more
i mean the emotional and mental energy
yeah
the decision making the conversations
the big deals the steakness
yeah it's a lot of energy it's a lot
that's why
i mean if you really want to achieve
your dreams you have to care for your
body yeah your mind it's why all these
things you know finally resonating in
the marketplace because the science of
meditation or taking a break or
you know
managing your own energy sleep is
everything yeah
and i think all of that is really
important and we say generate energy
because there's this myth that
you know some people have happiness or
they have it's like
no you generate you don't have happiness
you generally create it yeah you create
it and so
the quality of your energy you have to
create like you and i both i mean if
most of our audience knew
our schedules your schedule the last
five days was like how is lewis even
able to focus right now and how are you
able to get here and do this as well
yeah but it's because we say well this
is our mission
show up man yeah there's plenty of times
i gotta imagine you walked on the field
and you were like
i'm spam exhausted you know i remember
when you like flew down to compete and
yeah i still play with the usa team
handball yeah team and a year ago i flew
down to i remember i did an interview in
miami and then flew out from miami and
then went and just went right into
training camp and then played against
brazil which is like you know olympic
olympic qualifiers and yeah got our
assets booked but it was fun you know
but i had to have clarity yeah show up
even when i was like oh we're gonna lose
yeah like there's deer a chance yeah it
was like the worst team in the nba
playing like the warriors and we were
just like we had no chance yeah but i
had to show up and give my best and you
have to set all these routine i mean you
know the amount of routines that tom
brady has in his life so that he can
generate energy it's unbelievable stuns
most people it's unbelievable and that's
just that's that's what it takes if you
want to take that level if you don't
want to be at that level you don't have
to do it yeah you don't have to do it i
mean everybody can just like well i'm
gonna go you know hit the cinnabon but
it's like
it's pretty good how do you want to feel
at three o'clock if you wanna feel
amazing at three o'clock don't end lunch
with a cinnabon reveal uncertainty
this one
is the opposite dynamic of how i used to
think of confidence right we think of
confident people as people are just like
you know it's like wonder woman right is
confident we think of superman is
confident who just knows everything
really what it turns out to be high
performers are a lot listen to this high
performers are a lot less superman and a
lot more clark kent
that's what it turned to be in all their
research with millions of data points in
all of my conversations high performers
were much more likely to reveal
things like
i don't know
things like
i'm i'm unsure
things like how do you think this should
go
things like could could you kind of help
me with this
like high performers literally
explicitly share
that they don't know how it's going they
don't know how it's supposed to go that
they need some help that they need some
mentorship that they need some guidance
that's confidence
confidence is not holding back
the deck of cards of your weaknesses
confidence
is a comfort with vulnerability
and when people say vulnerability they
often don't know what they mean when
we're talking about vulnerabilities
specifically related to confidence and
high performance like measurable
outcomes
the thing that we can measure and see is
that high performers in group meetings
in team meetings in social situations
more often share their insecurity
they more often say
i don't know how this is supposed to go
or you know they'll be the person you
know
at that fruit punch bowl who says you
know i don't really know anybody here um
i don't really know how to start to uh
meet some of these people could you
introduce me to somebody
and that's how they handle the social
networking where they're awkward
they
instead of just sitting back at the
punch pole drowning their sorrows and
feeling bad about themselves they engage
the person next to them say hey you know
what i feel kind of awkward here i don't
know a lot of people could you introduce
me
that's how high performers are handling
little situations in life they're not
the most confident person in the meeting
who goes i know everything here they're
the most confident going you know what i
don't know this here's my question what
do you guys think
and that is how you lead confidently you
reveal that you don't know everything
those who learn to endure
struggle challenge difficulty
pain grief
vulnerability failure um regret
that's one side of that coin
if you learn to do that but you also
know on the other side
learn to allow
joy fulfillment satisfaction a sense of
hold up hold on i have to stop you allow
is that the word you want to commit to
you said bring i'm going to build okay
build it
you have to first allow it because what
most people do is
if on the other side of the coin it's
super etched in
what happens is even when that impulse
comes up i like this oh no i'm not
supposed to like it this is what so you
have a lot of people who are extremely
talented
at the top levels who they do endure the
pain and they really like the pain and
they will allow that all the day long
they'll allow that now because they'll
tell their brain
this is what's expected
but they also don't let themselves feel
good
when feeling good is there
this is a really big problem i mean if
you study like psychosis a lot of people
who really struggle with addictions
um eating disorders are super common who
even when they feel that sense of self
love or self accept oh i'm not supposed
to feel that no you really
there is an element
to personal development where you have
to allow the good feelings and not push
them away because it's like i should i
don't deserve to feel that because a
huge part of the world is telling
themselves i don't yet deserve to feel
happy even though happiness comes up i
shouldn't feel that yet i'm going to
keep striving it's not until i get the
next 2 million then i'll let myself feel
happy even though they had that good
monday
and so you have a lot of people who are
striving in difficulty
who also have not taught themselves the
emotional side
of what is called
the most important movement in the
history of the world in psychology
called positive psychology kicked off by
marty seligman a good friend of mine
mihaly just sent me high without that
work of saying no no we also have to
allow ourselves
and teach ourselves to flourish feel
satisfaction feel joy so i'm 100 with
you and i'm like the rule is that's one
side of the coin
and the other rule is
make sure you teach yourself
to generate the positive emotions
because what happens is if you don't
teach yourself to generate the positive
emotions as well then what ends up
happening is you burn out or
you become a cliche of the person who
had it all
and never felt fulfilled high performers
are not dissatisfied strivers
they're not they're happy high
performers are happier than their peers
we all believe that to get the top it's
going to be lonely at the top and we all
believe you have to grind and kill
yourself to get there yeah and that's
completely wrong and the data proves it
worldwide
which is i think just overcoming a lot
of people's biases about how you work
today because right now
especially today like you know grind on
social media is so popular or hustle or
hustle and by the way none of the top 15
of high performers worldwide
identify with those words they literally
don't we asked them we did a whole
keyword analysis yep this was actually
pretty cool and high performers
explicitly say these these are the three
driving feelings if we said there was a
high performance state it's driven from
these three things number one full
engagement yes number two
joy yes
and number three confidence yes that's
what they relate with okay that's where
it's coming from it's a joyous journey
not a dissatisfied one and this i have
this conversation in the book um
because
uh i kind of maybe
frame it this way each of these chapters
opens with a vignette
of somebody i worked with or a situation
that i was in that demonstrated high
performance in this particular situation
i'm walking on stage
thousands of people
after a very famous musician was out
there and was telling the audience that
that person's secret to success maybe
thousands of people yes their secret to
that person their whole speech their
secret to success was
never settle
never settle nothing is enough never
settle and never be satisfied never be
satisfied always demand more and i'm
like oh
my second slide which is going to be on
jumbotrons in like 80 point text
was strive satisfied
i'm like oh i'm gonna have to dispel
this for all these thousands of people i
was totally freaked out yeah
and but what i had to explain to people
was not only the data
but it's this
uh
if you're never satisfied
i mean what
is it true that life is precious
if it's true that life is precious and
you could be gone tomorrow do you really
want to think you know what i just never
felt fulfilled
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of credit
i never allowed myself to have a moment
of peace i never allowed myself to look
at that and say good job
that's not the way to live life right i
think just at a spiritual level it's a
bad move and this book doesn't really go
in a lot of that it's more about the
science and the heart stuff
but i think it's really important that
people realize
your job is to strive satisfied and if
you strive satisfied more often
you will be more of a high performer and
if you never give yourself credit you're
always beating up on yourself you're
always thinking that's not perfect
enough
then what's going to happen dissatisfied
people burn out and they quit
more often
than satisfied strivers so take joy in
the moment
engage with what you're doing
allow credit and satisfaction enjoy to
come in you can always be improving of
course but be proving be improving
joyfully i was a
maybe 24 25 year old man and i was a
member of kiwanis and if you guys didn't
know kiwanis was is a it's kind of like
rotary or lions club um it's uh it's a
a
it's a non-profit organization that's
dedicated towards service in in the
community and i was in kiwanis and i was
the youngest one hands down like in in
the room we'd get together every single
month on a tuesday and we'd have lunch
and we'd have a speaker in and then we'd
talk about a volunteer project we were
going to do that month and that was kind
of how it went in kiwanis for me and so
but in my room
i was 24 25 in the room every tuesday
um when we got together
everyone else was older i mean they were
like
50s and 60s and 70s older when i was 20
i was the youngest person in the room
every single time
and
i remember i was having a particularly
challenging time because i was thinking
about quitting my job but i was scared
because i didn't i hadn't saved any
money
um
i
didn't know exactly what i wanted to do
i just knew that i i knew that the job
wasn't the thing at the time
but i didn't know what it was and so i
was scared to make the leap and i was
just i was kind of struggling with some
existential stuff because you know it'd
been four or five years i hadn't had a
girlfriend
and it was just frustrating i was like
dating but i wasn't able i just wasn't
making real connections on when i was
dating and i was just unhappy in that
part of my life i didn't know what i was
doing with my career i didn't have a
significant relationship i was like oh
man
i'm just kind of i didn't feel good and
so i was having a really
down day
on that particular tuesday and i went in
and i was sitting next to this guy and
he was one of the just one of the
awesome kawanians that who was there and
he was um i think he was probably 59 60
years old he was in banking um very
successful wealthy guy happy hap just he
was like a happy-go-lucky grandpa type
you know just a good dude and i'm just
kind of listing off to him all these
things that suck
you know
and he says what are you doing about it
and i said well you know i
you know and he says well i bet and he
said i bet i know what's going on he's
you're going home you're probably
watching too much tv drinking too much
beer and
sitting alone too often or you're going
out and not having any fun and
we're just talking my mode was yeah i
kind of i go inside so i kind of pull
away from people when i'm unhappy
and so i was like yeah i kind of pulled
away and i'm in my house and he says why
i know how to solve your problem
i said oh what is it he goes buy tickets
like buy ticket when you buy tickets he
goes i want you to open up the paper
remember the papers says i want you to
open up the paper and he goes i want you
to see what's going on in your town
and i want you to buy tickets
to whatever's coming up the next seven
weekends
is it is there a symphony coming to town
buy tickets is there a ballet buy
tickets is there a uh an art museum buy
tickets is there he said is there a
concert buy tickets
and i said what do you mean i buy
tickets i want you buy one two three
four tickets and i want you to take your
friends and i just want you to go i want
you to buy tickets and i want you to go
and i'm like what the hell does this
have to do with anything i'm even
talking about he goes just buy the
tickets and come back next month tell me
about the tickets and i'm like no and he
literally pulls out his wallet and i'll
never forget he sets down three one
hundred dollar bills
and he goes
buy the tickets here's the money and i'm
like what are you even i was literally
so frustrated it's a long story short
i'll try to keep it shorter but so i
bought tickets i got like a symphony
ticket i uh got a there was like a dance
troupe in town or something weird um
there's a dave matthews concert
and what else there's one other thing i
can't remember what it was uh shoot
there's something about the tickets i
went with one or two or three friends
and
went to them and the second i remember
even i remember
the opening act for the dave matthews
band started and i was like
got it
got it
because sometimes when you're down and
out
you got to get out and about
and so
i was down and out and he got me out and
about and then with you with your
friends and you're socializing and it's
in a new environment and things are
happening and my mind just started
turning on again i started getting all
these ideas and these dreams that i
don't know where they were they weren't
in my room they weren't in my bed these
ideas and dreams they weren't happening
in my journal the the the ideas and
dreams they weren't happening in my my
daily planner it was like i was stuck
there so he moved me over here have you
ever been like at a ballet or a symphony
in orchestra and you're just sitting
there
and all of a sudden
you feel
amazing like the music hits you this
idea comes in and you walk out and you
feel amazing have you ever gone to
broadway show you went in and you were
frustrated and freaked out because all
the horrible new york traffic and all of
a sudden you
laugh your ass off and you leave the
broadway show and you feel like a
million dollars and now no problem is
gonna slow you down
that's buy tickets
buy tickets to seminar buy tickets to
the event buy tickets to the art museum
the ballet buy tickets and i mean if
you're down and out and your life sucks
right now go buy tickets for the next
four weeks and i promise you'll be like
damn
buy tickets that changed my life
changed my life too and i've learned
ever since then like if i'm down and out
it's like buy tickets when you get the
life is really short and you felt that
before either by you were threatened or
you've had someone near your near and
dear die but when you have that real
essence in you that says life is short
have reverence for it live it that's a
really big thing i got that at 19 and i
learned specifically
that
if we have a moment of cognition before
the end of our life
we tend to
ask questions to evaluate if we're happy
so if i have any impact in the world
it's
going to come from that experience where
i learned that the ultimate lesson is
determine
what the questions you're going to ask
at the end of your life are going to be
find out those questions what will you
ask at the end of your life
to evaluate your life
so that you would know if you were happy
with your life like figure out those
questions
and then live each day
intentionally so you're happy with the
answers at the end
for me the answers the questions i had
were did i live
which i hadn't i hadn't been living my
life i'd been thinking about taking my
life
did i love
no my heart was broken
and i put up all these walls to keep out
other people
and i always say you know sometimes the
walls we put up to keep out the bad guys
prevent the good guys from getting in
and suddenly in our own self-protection
we block out the very thing we want
which is connection
and i learned that i would ask did i
matter
you know 22 years ago
on a dark caribbean night i'm standing
on the crumpled hood of a car
bleeding out my friend
when i just wrecked a car he's screaming
at top of his lungs he's bleeding we
know if we're going to live
and i'm standing on this car
looking down all this blood
and i'm in
terror
and i just remember looking down the
hood and just thinking
did i even matter
you know
and i hated the answer at that time in
life
because a 19 year old kid i didn't know
about impact theory
for real i didn't know to think about
that you some you know young kids
sometimes they don't know to think about
that i didn't know to think about
legacy
meaning
did i matter i didn't think i did
but the good news is
i'm a good learner
and i felt like i got a second chance
from god that night and
i learned
that it was really important for me
to figure out how do i live and how do i
love and how do i matter in such a way
that if i face my death again i'll know
i've earned the second chance
and so what i want to tell people and
the impact i want is i just want people
to know know your questions man live
intentionally and earn the life that
you've been given because this moment's
a blessing so earn this moment and live
intentionally know your why is nice know
your why and give yourself edge for it
what do you mean give me an example two
guys walking out on the track field
who's gonna win well equal quality of
experience
similar times maybe they've raced before
the guy at the block so i'm going to bet
on is the guy who came out and said
i gotta do this for my mom
they have a reason to perform at
heightened levels
and they have connected to that over and
over
now again some of these duh brendan but
the finding the research is they just do
that more often
than underperformers or even you know
good performers yeah they're more
connected to their reasons why and
they're stirring it man it's like and
they do it from two angles one angle is
your your like your internal standards
like my values or my self-expectations
say i gotta crush this because that's
who i freaking am yeah like when you
walk out you're like
you're not gonna you know screw around
on when you're playing handball you're
like this is who
i'm loose i'm an athlete yeah i'm gonna
kick some ass here yeah it's that self
expectation okay then though they pair
it
with external obligation
like my team needs me to do this
the deadline says this time there's some
kind of external
they don't call it pressure my family
something bigger than themselves
something bigger themselves yeah yeah
and that's why that was another thing i
was surprised by they don't say
they they rarely use the word pressure
because they want it
like people who use pressure they don't
want it
but high performers
i found they want they like they're
connected i'm doing this for a bigger
cause a bigger reason a team or yeah
they're sometimes just like deadline
like i'm i'm an unbelievably high
performing writer when there's a
deadline
a weapon right
before that you know i'm not always on
my game so but if you have those reasons
so you gotta have your internal reasons
and your external reasons and then your
job is remind yourself of that more
often passion plus growth plus
contribution equals personal
satisfaction yeah
yeah it's like
those all coming together a lot of
people have never experienced
and it's hard for you and i'd say that's
personal development guys
but it's true there's a lot of people
who've never had those three completely
line up so they're not satisfied even
with
their job or their career or their life
because the passion isn't there
even if the passions are they don't feel
like they're growing but everybody i
talk to do you remember that first
personal development book you read do
you remember that first time you wrote
tons of notes about what you wanted your
life to be about do you remember that
first time you watched a movie inspired
you to go change there was fire there
because that learning
it opened up your mind to a new level of
existence for you
and soon as you saw it you were like oh
ambition hits your heart
and now if you can match it with
contribution and you can see
how
that passion or that fire or that
learning or that growth all aligns to
some type of impact
now you're getting me fired up
because now i can see the outcome
of all the work a lot of people don't do
the work because they don't believe the
outcome
that's interesting you know if
psychologists talk about the power of
expectancy
when we talk about motivation there's
only two things that spark motivation
one is ambition
and that is i want more
of or i want a greater depth of right i
want a greater depth of connection with
my lady that's ambition where i want a
better meditative practice that's
ambition all right i want to be better
at my job that's ambition so it starts
with ambition but ambition if it's not
coupled with what they call expectancy
in psychology you're screwed
expectancy says i believe that i can
figure that out i believe that i can
achieve that i believe that that is
possible for me
because if we don't believe it's
possible for me you can show them all
the results from a thousand people
right how many people say i want to get
in great shape
you know i'm
tom i'm a new ketosis i'm doing the
ketosis thing man and they hop on your
instagram and then they see they see the
cuts they see the changes they see the
transformations but they don't believe
it's possible for them
so they don't try
expectancy is their problem you gotta
bust through the beliefs to get them to
understand that it is possible for them
not for other people for them
and if you can open that gate for
somebody
and
often that's only achieved through
learning
then you get somebody who starts really
moving ahead forward i mean really
moving ahead like the second they go
wait that's possible for me they'll try
50 stupid things right they'll try
anything
but if they don't lose possibly then
they'll just quit i remember when i was
going to start my business and i i
really wanted to be good at it you know
i was trying to become an author and a
speaker and do these types of videos and
do some online training for people on
the topics of motivation and marketing
and you know some all these people are
saying well brendan you know you may or
may not be successful with that you're
you know blah blah and i thought it's a
weird thing it's not like there's a
trait of successful people you look
across history and successful people
it's not uh they're not from a given
background they don't come from a
specific economic stature they're not in
a position where you know they're
they're one demographic or another
democrat it's all over i mean we've got
thousands of collective years of history
people succeed some people do some
people don't and i think it more comes
down to how do we manage our mind and
how do we manage our days
and i think that there's a difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people in the way they
particularly think about
approaching something new
you know i think unsuccessful people
when they have a big dream and they
start thinking about what's going to be
required to accomplish that dream they
get very limiting in their beliefs about
themselves and what's possible and
specifically they say three types of
things you know the first thing they
often say is well
you know i don't know how to do that
so they stop
they say you know i i don't have those
things
so they stop
or they say i don't know
you know i'm not like those people i'm
not like that
and so they stop
but successful people have a different
way the same thing everybody dreams you
dream i dream successful people dream
people just starting out everybody
dreams everyone has a vision everyone if
they can just take five minutes today
and think about their lives we could all
come up with ways to improve our lives
and reach another level of success joy
happiness achievement contribution
fulfillment soul you know we can all
elevate
but the challenge is that the
unsuccessful people they keep stopping
when they think of what they currently
know have or are but successful people
say well i want to do that but i don't
know how to do that but instead of
stopping they say well then
my job
is to go learn that
they take their current limitation
and they put it on their agenda
as a job to do as a thing to figure out
a thing to make happen instead of saying
well i don't have that
they say well then my job is to go build
that or i'm not like that then they say
well then my job is to go become more of
that become that person who could
accomplish those things you know when i
was starting to do online marketing for
the first time and and i don't know if
you how much of my story you know but
when i started doing online marketing i
was literally bankrupt and i went from a
place of bankruptcy to the point where i
really committed to becoming successful
at it and in 18 months i made 4.8
million dollars
4.6 collected it was a huge leap right
in in indifference from bankrupt to
multi-millionaire in the span of 18
months
but what made that breakthrough wasn't
that i had new opportunities it wasn't
that i had new technologies it was like
wow there's the internet now those
things were already there
it went i went from this level of
thinking to this level of thinking i
used to say well i i don't know how to
build a web page
so i said agenda figure out how to build
a web page and i spent hours and hours
and hours at nights on weekends from my
job figuring out how to do that and i
said well i don't have one of those
lists you know i don't have any
subscribers nobody knows who i am so i
said job
go build a list go get subscribers go
add value and content out the
marketplace and they'll come i mean just
keep putting stuff out there and i also
didn't say oh my gosh well i have that
dream i can't have that because i'm not
like that because i wasn't a public
speaker i didn't know how to do video i
wasn't like well i'm not one of those
video people well i'm not a public
speaker so i said you know what i have
to go learn that art i have to go become
a better speaker a better communicator i
have to go become more confident i have
to go become a person capable of doing
these things i have to change myself to
get there i can't wait for circumstances
to change so i can have my dream then
our dreams would never happen we have to
get to the point of maturity in our
lives where we say okay two things are
gonna change my life something new is
gonna come into my life and make me
lucky and blessed and maybe i can't
count on that forever and maybe now
instead i have to consciously design my
life and say okay now if i want to
change if i want my dream something new
has to come from me
i'm going to become a better person i'm
going to become a person who is more
optimistic who is more confident who is
more driven not because i am that now
but because we can grow
that you can become the type of person
who needs to uh who you need to be to
achieve your ideal life you can start
today living from your highest ideals
your highest sense of self your
strongest sense of self you don't need
permission you don't need a guy like me
to look at the video camera and say you
have now permission but if you've been
waiting for it you have permission it's
like at some point in your life you just
say okay i have permission to become my
best self and by becoming your best self
you start to achieve your best things
you start to contribute better things
you start to become a better human being
you can do that now today so next time
you're thinking about a big dream don't
think about the things that well i don't
know how to do that and stop think i
don't know how so set it up on your
calendar to go learn those things i
don't have that then set it up step by
step to go build that i'm not like that
then set it up step by step to go
develop those skill sets and those
competencies so you can become that and
ultimately you can achieve that dream
it's there it's waiting for you don't
stop in our lives
especially when we're being
reactive
information comes in
right we're at events we're paying
attention to how people treat us
we're studying something we're trying to
learn something uh and we're just going
about our regular day
information is coming in how people
perceive us
the cause and effect of events
things are just happening
information comes into the brain from
that point the information immediately
goes into
interpretation
and what this usually means is
interpretation in the fast reactive
thing is safe
unsafe
good
bad
like it
don't like it
recognize it
don't recognize it
been there done that unfamiliar familiar
certain uncertain fear safe all these
things start triggering it's pretty
unconscious and it's pretty fast our
biases come into play it's just that
speed spontaneous reactive part of us
and it's that's not always bad sometimes
it can be good
right sometimes it can be good
interpretation can be that event that's
good for me
or that events that's bad for me but
usually it's like a snap judgment think
about that most
most when we're talking about an
unconscious level it's like a snap
judgment automatic like you like her
don't like her
feel safe don't feel safe it's very fast
then the next level and this is not
always linear of course because your
brain
is not left brain
right brain kind of
methodology your brain is more of a
spider web of interconnectedness that is
something we still don't understand okay
you can study everything in neuroscience
and you might learn something about this
lobe or that
that cortex region but then only to find
out that later on a year later like well
actually it seems like it's also
communicating over here it's a spider
web of unbelievable
intelligence it's happening that and
everything can be millisecond
hundreds of million seconds
of transitions between neural networks
it's unbelievably fast unbelievable
capable so this is just for our
understanding it's not necessarily real
world linear like this but what tends to
happen is as information comes in good
bad we also then move it to
a level of well what does this mean to
me
identity
what does this mean to me what does this
either mean to me or what does this say
about me
how does this apply to me
and if we're not conscious here this can
be really troublesome some of you
discovered that yesterday i bet when you
released a few things sometimes we have
these events in our life that we we take
on and we just assume it meant something
about us and we didn't realize no that's
more of a statement about them than it
is about us
right sometimes when you're hurt or
someone was rude to you it had nothing
to do with you raise your hand to follow
i had nothing to do with you but if
you're not careful
you could say
mean person unsafe means i'm bad child
rude behavior
uncertain about this
i must not be long
terrible situation
i feel bad
i can never be safe again
how many follow how this happens
this is why we have to be very very very
observational of our own thoughts and
feelings because how these things get
labeled
can really change our lives forever
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there